in the last video we discussed the great
compromise made at the Constitutional
Convention in 1787 where delegates who
were trying to craft a new governmental
system for the United States agreed on
how the legislative branch of the
government would be set up and the
agreement they made was that it would be
a two house or bicameral legislature
with a House of Representatives where
the representatives would be apportioned
based on state population and then a
Senate where every state would get two
senators regardless of its size and this
is just one example of how with the
framers of the Constitution try to
introduce a notion of balance in this
video I want to zoom out a little bit
and look at the broader Constitution
because the legislative branch was
really only one part of it fact there
are seven more articles of the
Constitution so here I'd like to spend
some time taking a closer look at some
of the other articles paying special
attention to the executive branch and
the judicial branch but before we do
that I just want to take a moment to
marvel at the size of the Constitution
not because it's so big but because it's
so small so this is the first page of
the Constitution famously starting with
We the People but the entire original
Constitution could fit on four pages
compare that to the Constitution's of
many other nations which are hundreds of
pages long and I think the idea here and
having a constitution that's really only
seven articles long was that I was going
to set down principles this wasn't going
to be a whole set of laws that outlined
everything that a state should do in any
situation but rather a set of broad
ideas around which lawmaking decisions
could happen in a way you could think of
the Constitution as being kind of broad
enough to be flexible they spoke in
larger generalities that could be
applied to many different situations and
I think the proof that this was a good
way to think about putting together a
constitution is just in the fact that we
still have this constitution today more
than 200 years after it was written in
1787 the US Constitution is the oldest
Constitution in the world that is still
in effect at the national level I think
that's a pretty big deal so how did this
constitution work well let's look a
little bit more closely at these first
three articles and the branches of
government that they created so one of
the ways that the framers of the
Constitution attempted to remedy the
problems caused by the single branch
government under the Articles of
Confederation was creating a three
branch government so one branch
established an article one would be the
Congress and within this building is the
House of Representatives and the Senate
and this would be in the eyes of the
framers really the most powerful of the
branches they gave Congress the power to
make law to tax to raise an army to coin
money they really envisioned that most
of the day-to-day operations and most of
the power of government would fall under
the duties of Congress but one thing
that the Articles of Confederation had
lacked was a powerful executive so the
second branch of government established
an article to is the executive branch
the head of which is the president and
the job of the executive would be to
enforce or carry out the laws made by
Congress and that would include doing
things like waging war remember that the
first president was George Washington
who had been the general of the
Revolutionary Army
but the president could also kind of
have the front lines on dealing with
foreign nations so negotiating treaties
and would also have the power of
appointing many government officials and
lastly the third branch would be the
judicial branch of government
established an article three and the
head of the judicial branch would be the
Supreme Court the highest court in the
land of course there are many other
smaller courts below it at the state and
district level and the Supreme Court's
job along with other courts would be to
interpret the law to see whether or not
things done by Congress and the
president fell within the bounds of the
Constitution and the framers really
thought that the judicial branch would
end up being the weakest branch of
government although both the presidency
and the Supreme Court have grown in
power over the years now this is an
incredibly brief overview of these three
branches these articles include lots
more in them about the specific powers
of each of these branches and the kinds
of requirements one would need to become
a representative or president so I
highly recommend that you read more
about the Constitution and check out
these articles but what I want you to
get out of this is that the framers here
we're trying to separate the powers of
government so they wanted to make sure
that to avoid having too much power in
government remember that they are trying
to escape from the monarchy they want to
make sure that government power is kind
of diffused among these three branches
with the idea that they're going to have
to argue with each other to get things
done they're going to have to cooperate
with each other to get things done so
the separation of powers is one of the
key principles of the Constitution
another key principle is checks and
balances so what do I mean by checks and
balances well this is the idea that each
of the branches of government has the
power to check in the sense of stop like
checkmate
in chess the other branches of
government and I think of this is kind
of like a giant governmental game of
rock-paper-scissors now there are many
ways that these branches can check each
other but I just want to give a couple
of quick examples to help you understand
what that might be like all right well
say that Congress makes a law and the
president doesn't like that law well the
president can use the power of the veto
to kill that law and if Congress gets
annoyed enough with the president they
might use their power to impeach the
president all right well what about the
judicial branch so the judicial branch
is main checking function is declaring
laws unconstitutional so the President
or Congress may put through a law that
the Supreme Court says is not consistent
with the Constitution judicial branch
can then kill that law by declaring it
unconstitutional all right well what
happens if the other branches are
unhappy with the judicial branch one way
that the president can check the
judicial branch is through appointing
judges this would kind of change the
composition of the court the people on
the court and so over time the
presidency can influence who is on the
Supreme Court and how they rule on laws
and lastly if Congress isn't happy with
the Supreme Court they might be able to
impeach justices or change jurisdiction
of the lower courts so in this way like
the separation of powers the framers
intended to make sure that one branch
couldn't get too powerful because it
would be able to check the other
branches
and you could really think of this as
being a brilliant way of harnessing
people's natural inclination to look out
for themselves as rivalries developed as
people tried to do what they thought was
best they could help keep government
honest by fighting among themselves and
as they all strove and checked each
other would keep all of government from
becoming too powerful